[Musique]
depuis sa naissance le petit mec n'a pas
encore mis le nez hors de l'hôpital
sainte justine
aujourd'hui nous ont reçu la visite d'un
père noël bien spéciale s'affaisse bien
c'est phone on est dedans ça va faire un
monde on est ici face à l'état des
patrons l'appréhendent un peu fax
téléphone avoir des belles visites comme
ceux de saint cirq
on n'est pas dans ses demandes et nous
non
et
kent nagano effectué six visites dans
les hôpitaux depuis son arrivée à
montréal en 2006 une tradition qui lui
est cher c'est important pour nous comme
oui comme être humain mais aussi comme
comme anti sq que musicien de partager
une autre confrontés
dans les couloirs de l'hôpital le bruit
des respirateurs et des alarmes a fait
place à des arts de pâques de mozart et
à des perceuses
le répit mérité et qui fait du bien et
des petits moments qui nous hissons son
éphémère mais qui qui apporte énormément
de bonheur un soulagement
autant aux enfants qu'aux parts on voit
qu'ils sont capables de lâcher prise
l'espace d'un instant ils ont pu oublier
leurs tracas et profiter du pouvoir
réconfortant de la musique pour les
enfants
pour nous aussi là ça nous apporte
l'ambiance de noël la joie la musique ça
nous apporte énormément d'émotion ce
qu'on vivait dans les jambes justement
c'est que l écoute de la musique du
départ des violences la convention
voyelles le petit cas des enfants sur
les ventes a requis 40 et une belle
journée riche en émotions pour les
petits et les grands
on est profondément ému je vais tout de
suite parlé avec mes enfants comme quand
on rentre chez nous pour partager ses
expériences
une expérience qui a semblé séduire les
petits spectateurs pour qu'il s'agissait
dans bien des cas deux premiers concerts
de musique classique
oui est-ce que tu connaissais la
dernière chanson oui c'est dix neuf ans
non c'était bien c'était impressionnant
kent nagano c'est bien
soyez prêts à vous aussi à vous aussi
joinel ici nabi alexandre charti radio
canada montréal
[Applaudissements]